Victoria is a retired special ice agent
and he joins us today mr. via thank you
very much for coming on Thank You Tucker
for having me on so what do you what do
you make of this the technological wall
the vanity project you've spent your
life policing our borders do we need a
physical wall an actual wall well Tucker
I have to say this is personal I've
worked in Mexico I've worked on the
border and born and raised there I was
attacked and Jaime Zapata lost his life
agent Zapata right next to me while we
were an assignment in Mexico so I know
that this is real and the crisis is real
and the border wall is very much needed
this is the physical barrier that's
gonna help our border agents down there
help them just like that the other
technology would help them the the
drones the sensors all the other
technology that comes along the border
the border wall is just another tool
that's going to help them do that and
it's much needed so they could then
focus on those areas where that traffic
is gonna be infiltrated through so in
the shooting that you referred to you
were hit three times you were shot three
times by a member of a Mexican drug
cartel how do you get as someone who
went through that what's your response
when you hear members of Congress
congressional leaders say that there's
no crisis at all and that we're
imagining it and in fact it's racist to
say there's a crisis at the border how
do you respond to that the crisis is
real I've lived it I've worked at the
especially the racist comments is just
unreal Mexico now is looking at to
starting to control their own so their
border by sending their own federal
troops down to the whatta malleable east
border because now they're feeling the
impact of these immigrants coming
through their country and so are they
going to be racist as well and so it's
just absurd to to think that it it makes
it a racist statement because you want
or makes you a racist because you want a
wall but let me tell you what's really
in morale what's in morale is the
exploitation of our asylum laws Congress
needs to shut down and and redo that all
those Asylum laws and legislation
I'll give you example Tucker if if an
adult person comes into the country with
a minor child and presents themselves to
the Border Patrol and turns himself in
seeking asylum if that adult person has
a criminal history in and it's known to
have a criminal history Border Patrol is
gonna have to still admit that person in
with the child even though that person
is now inadmissible to come into this
country will have to allow to come in
and with the child to seek wait for
their asylum hearing two to three years
from now and we'll never hear from that
person and maybe that adult person is or
not the the parent of that child and
we'll never know what happens to a child
as well so there's a real crisis at the
border happening on right now have you
spoken to the Speaker of the House Nancy
Pelosi or two Democratic leaders as they
as they formulated their position in
this debate over the border wall it has
anyone talked to you no but I would love
to there is a major disconnect between
Washington and and Congress and what's
going down in real life in the border it
would be so effective to have them just
at least go down there and not just for
the photo-op or just for you know for a
ten minute walk where there's actual
wall that actually works thanks to Jim
Acosta but to actually learn what the
real crisis is down there not not today
Tucker this has been going on for
decades it's just now the influx and I
talked to Border Patrol agents and they
tell me and they're they want this
response to go forward with the wall
they're so afraid that if this doesn't
go through they can't imagine the influx
of illegal immigrants trying to come
through because they're gonna be sending
the wrong message yeah I can't imagine
how you feel I mean if I if I was shot
three times by a drug cartel and watch
my partner murdered and then someone
called me a racist because I wanted a
wall I don't know how you remain so calm
but I'm certainly impressed that you do
mister via thank you very much for
joining us and for what you had to say
thank you took over having me